that's what I love though about these
like human drama shows is that like
sometimes they may just be like the
simplest thing of like just a story
between two people yeah one person but
if it's done really [ __ ] well it can
be some of the most powerful [ __ ]
storytelling I think it's more relatable
than at most things and it's really
uncomfortable to think that you could be
in a situation where you've to come to
terms with your death that's why that's
why I like you know I'll say this till
the end of time but late that's the
whole reason why my favorite manga
artist of all time is in your sauna I
was gonna say that one the one series
that the one manga series that I'm like
I'm still wasting want to be in the
right headspace to read is oh you ask me
pred that I've reread that like two or
three times like all the way through and
every time I'm just like oh no the only
way it's just oh no yeah because it's
just so like and it's not just poon
phone as well like any other sauna is
just so good at writing these characters
that are just so believable yeah and
it's really disturbing when you see
these characters these very believable
characters run into these very
believable and horrifying situations and
you're just like this is like based off
like a real person's life and that's
just scary in and of itself because this
guy can just think of stuff like this
yeah yeah and present it in a way that
is just so terrifying like it's for like
when people like man danganronpa is
really like despair for please shut the
it's got pink blood for fun like like
real despair is like uncomfortable
pissed off so many Duncan Rouleau fans
don't you see these characters like
they're about to dine down wrong [ __ ]
gives a [ __ ] yes cuz I feel like there
are certain levels cuz like everything
though ever the series that we've talked
about is just like it hits you I know I
don't want to say it but like it hits
different to a reason why you should
watch this if you're like me I'm a
person who avoids these kind of shows
like the why cuz I cry at like any
I cry out like deku when he says
anything in my ear academic but my deku
screams even like a little bit I'm like
dementias I don't know why it's like a
human reaction I'll cry of anything so I
know what shows that I can tell my brain
often yeah I don't want to have to get
into like foxy
I'm really scared you know I really just
like what now that you've said that I
really want you to read looking in your
son no I know it's gonna ruin it and
that's why like III stay away from it
but like please watch Bo Crowder you
know it's if you're in the right
headspace for that kind of show cause
like you know you know when you have
like social barriers up and yeah yeah
you see something that senior sad or
something it's like it's like yeah you
feel sad you cry or whatever but there
are some shows that you like you don't
know whether you want to cry or boy down
and just like disappear yeah yeah cuz
there's plenty of romance shows that
like you've really mmm
left me and kind of like very sad but
yeah it's a different feeling like it's
all different field and week made me
very sad a lot of the time we go to time
in time a golden time sorry yeah I'm an
ape um III like golden time a lot maybe
very sad you know very upset a lot of
time but like it's a it's just like a
it's not I don't leave that feeling like
oh man there's no hope anymore III felt
the same way when I watch Sarasa as well
because like there are some cuz like
that seems like all like oh yeah you
know cute you know kids in a room you
know just yeah but some of the back
stories of some of these characters I'm
just like [ __ ] man describe man that's
sad dude but yeah as you said it's not
like it's sadness and despair are just
two totally different emotions right cuz
cuz it's kind of like those kinds of
shows where you know I used the oh it
changed my life kind of kind of which is
really corny when you say it yeah but
it's just one of those shows where you
finish and you just sit down and you
just like staring at a blank Warren
you're like yeah it's the big scientist
you can't even like listen to the ending
song so I can't listen to this
maybe in silence right now like I
remember being very sad and
having a similar feeling watching Bojack
horseman and it taps in the same areas I
know you're laughing I by the way last
last last time we recorded this I said
an analogy we're amazing
Carano right to sum it up to you if
you're familiar with Bojack horseman bow
Khurana is imagine if Bojack horseman
had 12 kids and they were all equally as
[ __ ] up as Bo Jackson and then and
then they all had to get sacrificed and
he slowly got to hear the backstory of
these fucked-up bojack horseman children
it's so [ __ ] up and it's it's it's
like different because in Bojack it's
his own fault right and yes and it
whatever it's very very sad okay
whatever it hits differently